it's beauty junkie week because i
am a beauty junkie raise your hand
if you love makeup
i know gentlemen but you have something
you are doing
in your manscaping metrosexual
lives i know it so i am gonna we have
stories for you today as well
so don't worry because men have to do
and use the tools that they need to to
make yourself feel better
it's true it is all about the inside but
when we don't feel great on the inside
we work a little bit with the outside
and then both
have a symbiotic boost and this is what
we're talking about this week how we
look how we feel the little tricks and
tips
and all the fun that we do to ourselves
as human beings to primp and puff and
feel a little better
you know so we're celebrating all things
beauty and we're gonna kick it off
today with a fun experiment okay
vffs have any of you guys
experienced what they call in the beauty
world the dreaded melt and that's when
you're exercising
and your face is just melting off
basically i see some knotting i
love this okay great so there are a few
ways that you can avoid it and
one is to use water resistant makeup
like sweat cosmetics and later in the
show we're going to meet leslie osborne
who's the co-founder of sweat cosmetics
and victoria from morristown new jersey
is going to take it for a test run
victoria are you there hi girls
good morning gosh you are giving me
goals right now i feel like i need to do
this
like get my core activated all right
how's you how's it going
do you have dreaded makeup melt i do
i've had it so i'm so excited to try
this product
and make sure it works and so far so
good
well you look glowy dewy healthy
gorgeous you really have that high pro
glow
my goodness so let's you're welcome
you really are so beautiful so let's put
sweat cosmetics
to the test and you're gonna be biking
throughout the show
again i'm jealous i'm gonna get on that
bike with you and just ride
which is my new favorite word for like
let's go at our show
anything we're doing i'm like ride okay
so we're gonna check back in later with
you
and uh see how it's all holding up and
what you think
thank you see you soon thank you
really quick i want to check in with
victoria who's wearing sweat resistant
makeup by sweat cosmetics while biking
victoria how is it going
it's so great it's really going great i
feel great
my face is not sweating it's awesome i
will
say that you don't look any glossier or
dewier than the beautiful
moment we first saw you today
uh that's well then it's working all
right we're gonna check back in
keep going in fact can we check in with
victoria real quick and see how she's
rocking it still going victoria
making me feel like i am a lazy lazy
little couch potato
and i usually wake up at like four in
the morning to work out before work
and what did i do this morning i slept
until the last second
so thank you victoria for showing us how
it's done how are you feeling
i'm feeling great i'm really feeling
confident with this makeup so this line
is awesome
i really like it well thank you victoria